good morning everyone my name is Pippen
Kulkarni and I welcome you to the second
video of the CISSP series in this video
we are going to discuss the CISSP exam
and it's questions
the topics included in this video is
what is the exam all about you're going
to have an overview of the exam you are
going to discuss the eight domains in
cissp you are going to discuss what are
the topics within those domains and then
we are going to look at a few sample
questions of what kind of questions
would be would be asked in the exam what
should be the thought processes
answering them and what kind of
knowledge is required for us to
understand and answer those questions so
let's get started what is CISSP cissp
stands for the certified information
security or rather certified information
systems security professional it is
considered as a cool standard in the
field of information security it is a
management certification so when you are
in the senior management this is the
kind of certifications that you would
require for your management skills now
this is a non technical or a semi
technical certification here
it's nothing about vulnerability
assessment or penetration testing you
are not going to do anything hands-on
you are not expected to know hacking or
you are not expected to know how to
configure firewalls anti viruses and
whatnot it's basically something that
over a period of years of experience you
have evolved a certain understanding of
how security policies should be
constructed how they should be
implemented and how security effects an
organization so here you are responsible
to create a overall security policy for
an organization to help maintain the
security posture of an organization now
as far as the certification is concerned
it has a valid ET of three years after
which you don't have to give the exam
again however during these three years
you have to earn a certain point so it
is known as a continuing power education
points that IC square allows you to
generate points by attending lectures or
by attending webinars by republishing
white papers by providing trainings
obviously all of these should be
authorized and you should
have validation from authorized party
that you have done this activity once it
is verified you will be awarded certain
points once you have collected
sufficient number of points you will
retain your certification beyond the
three years the passing rate of this
examines less than fifty percent so it's
not how much you require to score what
this basically tells you is the amount
of people who actually clear the exam in
the first attempt now let's not get
disheartened because of this essentially
the exam is quite tough it's known as a
mile wide and an inch deep exam that
means you need to know just about
everything and anything that is there to
be known in information security and
that's something that we are going to
discuss when we go into the eight
domains of CISSP what happens is there
are a lot of people who are not actually
prepared for the exam good thing they
are prepared attempt the exam and that
will you fail in their first attempts
some people just miss just the exam I'm
not prepared for it so the fact that I'm
trying to put across is be very well
prepared I have seen people who study
for months together attempt a lot of
questions and show that their knowledge
is up to the mark and only then do they
attempt the exam
anybody can register for the exam to be
honest and clear the exam as well
however to get certified there are two
different avenues so if you have
experience of at least five years in two
of the domains that are in the CISSP
course you get certified so even if you
clear the exam there is a validation
process that happens after the example
you have to submit documentation to
prove to IC square that you have that
level of experience and once it is
proved proven and validated you get
certified as a CICS field if you do not
have that five years of experience you
get certified as an associate of IC
square for cissp and they give you six
years during which you can achieve the
level of experience prove it to them and
then get certified as a CIS SP so you
can see the stringent levels that are
taken for this certification the
validation is basically documentation
and prove that you have to submit and
which is verified so even after you
clear an exam to get validated and get
certified it can take up to five to six
weeks for IC square to validate and
provide
with the certification with that let's
go and see the exam let's have an
overview of what the exam is all about
the governing bodies is e squared that's
what we have been referring to and the
professional experience at least four
years of college degree or additional
credentials from ISC squares approved
list that will satisfy one year of
require experience and five years of
paid full-time work experience in two or
more domains like I said anybody can
give the exam register for it
attempt it once you clear then that's
where the criteria of your work
experience comes into the picture you
prove five years of experience probably
by a letter from your organization from
your HR saying you have this kind of
experience that is relevant to the
certification the ISIS query validated
you get the certification if you don't
have that experience you get associate
of IC square and then you get six years
to attain that level of experience after
which you can get certified the exam
fees one six hundred ninety nine dollars
so it's an expensive exam a single
attempt for each voucher so if you feel
that's another seven hundred dollars for
the second attempt the fact being if you
fail for the first time
you cannot attempt the exam for the next
thirty days if you fail for the second
time you cannot attempt the exam again
for the next sixty days and if you fail
for the third time you cannot attempt
the exam for another 90 days so there's
a cooling-off period after each attempt
so I would suggest study hard go for the
first attempt clear it and nail it the
maintenance fees for your certification
is again 85 US dollars for three years
the exam length is three hours and the
questions could vary from 100 to 150 150
being the max questions that can be
asked in that exam you can clear the
exam well before 150 questions so be
prepared for that as well
but imagine when you're walking into
that exam bear in mind that you will be
asked 150 questions and you have to time
those in 3 hours
180 minutes that's what 3 hours is so if
you do the math not much time for every
question so it's just a minute and a
half or less than that for each question
and the questions could be very
descriptive could be confusing so you
have to have your mental faculties
really strong during the exam the
passing score is 700
1,000 points exam language is English
testing centers there are is c-square
authorized centers where you need to
book that exam there's a huge process
that you have to follow to where where
you go for the exam itself so once you
have registered on the IAC Square portal
and you purchase the voucher they will
give you a list of centers in your
vicinity that he can look into they'll
give you a calendar to give you the
possible dates that you can attempt to
exam on select the center's select the
date reach the center at least half an
hour before the scheduled time there is
a verification so you have to carry your
identification a government-issued
document either a passport driver's
license where you have to prove that you
are who you say you are and once the
verification is done only then do you
get to attempt the exam the question
formats are three types multiple choice
drag and drop and hotspots multiple
choice is the format that we are going
to look at when we look at sample
questions it's the same they give you a
question they give you four options
either one or more options need to be
chosen
they will specify if there is more than
one answer to that particular question
in a drag and drop it's most like more
like match the following so there will
be a column a and column B and they'll
ask you a question and say okay column a
gives you the options drag and drop
whichever correct answer is in car is
from column a to call it B and then
submit the answer if the answer is
correct you get awarded the points else
there is no negative marking the third
is a hot spot hot spot question is
basically a diagram let's say a
architectural diagram that will be
presented to you and they will ask you
to pinpoint a certain aspect within that
diagram for example they may give you an
architectural overview of a network of
how it has been established and they
will ask you for a network based
firewall which is the most like list
area that you want the firewall to be
placed in so you don't need to know how
to configure the firewall but from an
architectural perspective you need to
know where that firewall needs to be
placed for it to be the most effective
for the given scenario in the question
these are the domains that are asked so
you can see it basically covers anything
and everything that is there in
information security it starts off with
security and risk management which
weighs 15 percent in your questions in
your exam so if your
Sam is 115 questions 15% would be around
around 2022 odd questions and risk
management being one of the most
important topics for these kind of
certifications then asset security which
covers twenty ten percent of your
questions so that's around fifteen
questions security architecture and
engineering this is where your
infrastructural knowledge your security
architects your enterprise architecture
all those come into the picture there
are a lot of theoretical models that you
need to study in domain three and that
covers thirteen percent of your exam
communications and network security this
is the most technical topic within all
these eight topics this is where you
talk about networks you talk about
tcp/ip you discuss protocols like TCP
UDP you discuss different attacks
man-in-the-middle attacks das attacks
and this basically has 14 percent of
wastage then you have Identity and
Access Management which basically talks
about users subjects objects subjecting
the user object in the resource and
relationship between these to be created
where people are authorized for some
activity authenticated and only then
allowed and also held accountable for
whatever activity they have done then
you go into security assessment and
testing so vulnerability assessments
penetration test software test testing
SAS tast a little bit all those will be
covered in domain number six which has
12 percentage then security operations
so security operation center or the sock
day-to-day management of incidents so
your incident management will come into
the picture of problem management change
management all of those things would
come under domain 7 as security
operations which has 13% of wait age and
then finally software development
security now you don't need to know
development or you don't need to know
any programming there are no program
based questions they're not going to ask
you how to code they're going to ask you
how to manage a software development
lifecycle or a secure software
development lifecycle so this is where
your waterfall model is modified
waterfall model spiral agile devops
steps AQAP's
all come into the picture and this has
10% of a tidge now it is we're about
impossible for everyone or anyone to get
experience across all these two means so
you will have your strong points and you
will have your
weak points the task is to identify
where you're good at understand those
things make the maximum out of it then
identify your weak points and start
developing condone those if you are able
to look at it from a theoretical
perspective however if you can get an
internship or if you can get you can say
just an insight of how it works in the
practical world it would be very helpful
now that being said as far as cissp exam
is concerned it involves a very ideal
world the real world actually doesn't
come into the question because the real
world will have a lot of business logic
to it by business logic what do we mean
every organization will modify their
projects based on the expertise that
they have based on the talent that they
have and based on the people or the
hierarchy of the organisation that has
been established so it can be customized
to each and every organisation since an
exam cannot deal with these kind of
customizations we deal with an ideal
world so for the CISSP exam you assume
that you have all the resources we have
all the people that are required we have
an hierarchy in the training which is
given out where we have rules for each
and every person and job titles for each
and every person right so when we go
through the training it is very
essential that we understand what these
job roles are what their
responsibilities are so that when we get
those questions we can identify which
person is going to attempt what in the
real world things are very different we
piggyback we take on multiple
responsibilities and that is something
that cissp doesn't adhere to so you have
to be very careful identify the job
roles identify the responsibilities have
that map the hierarchical map created
very well and then try to implement the
ideal world scenario from the CISSP
standards to see what is going to happen
that being said let's move on let's
discuss the domains now these domains we
have already seen what we can do is we
are going to move on to the sample
questions for each and every domain once
we reach the domain we'll see what the
topics in that domain are we will look
at the sample questions then we will
look and go to the next domain see the
topics in that domain and then look at
the sample questions as well so what to
study and those sample questions are
evolving them so looking at the first
module or
domain security and risk management now
this is one of the largest domains that
could be debatable for me I would say
the largest domain could be domain
number three security architecture and
engineering could also be domain number
four because it is quite technical
communications and network security and
could also be security operations
because that's incident management
change management problem management
altogether but each domain is very
important from the exams perspective if
you are thinking about keeping a domain
for options forget it that's not the
right way to address the exam let's
start off with the first one security
and risk management this domain teaches
you all about information systems
management and this talks about risks
and everything so what we are going to
do is we are just going to go to the
official document from IC square where
these domains and their topics are given
so that's the exam outline from CI sir
from IC square towards C is s speed is
the latest document that is they're
available online you can see the URL in
my browser address bar and these are the
eight domains this is the exam three
hours number of questions 100 to 150
multiple-choice and advanced intuitive
questions that's where the drag-and-drop
and the hot spot comes into the picture
though based on experience I can tell
you that 90% of your questions would be
multiple-choice 10% would either be drag
and drop and hot spots passing rate is
700 out of 1000 points exam language
availability is English those who want
to attempt in other languages it is
available but then the exam is six hours
and the questions are 250 so that's your
option depending on which language
you're most comfortable with we are
going to go with English that's the
language options coming in cissp linear
exam six hours 250 questions everything
else remains the same these are the
languages supported French German
Brazilian Portuguese Spanish Japanese
simplified Chinese and Korean the wait
age I guess remains the same and that's
the first to me security interest
management so what does it pertain to
understand and apply concepts of CI a
confidentiality integrity and
availability in the first video we have
gone through all the eight domains at
quite some length we have
what CIA is all about and how the
interrelationship is so if you want a
deep dive or rather a deeper dive than
what we are doing for the domains go
back to the first video look into that
and then you can come back to this video
again so evaluate and apply security
governance principles so we have to
understand what governance is now
governance is basically having a
overlying architectural security policy
that can be integrated with an
enterprise architecture and thus having
your security policy in alignment with
the prisoners goals and objectives
security should never become a hindrance
for a business security should always
become a supporting feature which should
allow the business to be executed in a
secure manner so as a security expert
our first goal is to identify what the
business does what the business
processes are what is the business
trying to achieve and then we try to
create a security policy revolving these
to enhance the business functionality in
a overall picture so you're looking at
organizational processes acquisitions
divestitures acquisition is when let's
say scenarios where you have trying to
create a security governance policy now
the business is trying to change because
they're trying to acquire another
organization and merge it within this
organization and now your security
policy should encompass not only your
organization but but the newly acquired
organization let's say the next five
years of business decides that the newly
acquired organization is no longer
profitable and they want to sell it off
and now that's where the divestiture
comes into the picture you are now
trying to separate the entity that you
have just integrated in your security
policy and you are now trying to
separate it with confidentiality
integrity and availability of the
company's data intact without affecting
the organization at any point in time I
understand the fact that Security's not
only about hacking or getting hacked
it's about being secure at all points in
time during business continuity and
business let's say business as usual
kind of activities so that's where your
security control frameworks would come
in you're going to talk about ISO 27001
you're going to talk about who built PCI
DSS NIST 800 series and so on so forth
and the most two important statements or
terms in the CSS piece do
here and due diligence do care is you
doing your own research to identify what
security controls need to be implemented
now what kind of governance needs to be
implemented and due diligence is you
yourself spending that much time money
effort into implementing those decisions
that you have come a come across during
the do you care
does enhancing the security for our
functions of an organization so when we
talk about business requirements for a
business to be effective at the same
time it needs to be legal it needs to be
compliant to regulations and laws and to
the contracts that have been created by
the organization so as far as the
concept goes when we say that security
needs to be in alignment with the
business requirements the business
requirements imply that the business is
legal is compliant to regulations is
compliant to the contractual obligations
and it's following standards that have
been prescribed to them so all of them
come together and that's where your
security mapping comes into the picture
you are looking at legal and regulatory
issues like cyber crimes and eita
breaches licensing and intellectual
property requirements and so on so forth
and it will also include IC squares code
of professional ethics now this is a
document apart from the eight domains
that we've talked about does what does
this talk the document talk about this
is the prescription from IC square of
professional ethics for a cyber security
professional expect around four to five
questions from professional ethics as
well so not only is there's a document
that you need to read and hear to you
will be questioned upon this in your
exam and these are easy points to score
professional ethics something that is
ethical something that is not against
the law so it's kind of quite easy but
the questions can be confusing so you
need to go through the entire document
really well and then your organization
will have its own code of ethics however
if you look at the hierarchy IC squares
ethics comes first so your organization
ethics should not be contradictory to IC
squares ethics in the first place then
develop document and implement security
policy standards procedures and
guidelines identify analyze and
prioritize business continuity
requirements so here that's where your
risk assessment comes into the picture
if you're looking at a particular risk
that means a particular vulnerability
has been identified you want to add
see the likelihood of that quality being
exploited and then the business impact
analysis that we have based on which you
would then create a plan to mitigate
that particular risk by having a
business continuity or a disaster
recovery plan coming into the picture
now this is as far as this domain is
concerned you're calculating the risk
it doesn't actually tell you how to
mitigate that risk that's when you go
into the next future domains and discuss
those technicalities so you can see
contribute and enforce personnel
security policies now the thing about
CISSP is physical security also comes
into the picture why because if Hardware
is not well protected there would be
physical attacks social engineering
attacks that could be created which
would lead to data leakage as well and
the first and the foremost most valuable
asset of an organization is always human
personnel so CISSP would also deal with
people protection in the first place for
example protecting people against social
engineering attacks making them aware
about these attacks if there are natural
calamities you have to plan a clear plan
for them during your disaster recovery
and business continuity plan and ensure
that people are safeguarded not only
that you have to tie these things up
with Identity and Access Management for
example account creation account
management onboarding of employees off
holding termination of employees third
party contractors consultants that you
are going to hire which are not
employees but third parties coming in to
your organization providing intelligence
and so on so forth so all of those come
into the picture as well and then that's
where your risk your management concepts
come in it gives you a very good
overview of how to identify those risks
and so on so forth now this is what the
in the first domain is all about it
itself is very huge and as we go ahead
we can tie this domain to the rest of
the domains for more deeper analysis go
to the first video and then we can come
back to this so let's start with the
questions the first question now these
are very short one-liner questions your
exams would be more descriptive to be
very honest with you if you go online no
matter what practice questions that you
try or whatever dumps if you can find
those you will find none of them will be
ever any close to the actual exam
questions you will find a lot of sites
online that's
you see ISSP dumps with a 100% guarantee
for you to clear don't fall for that
it's just a money-making scam those
questions will be similar questions
something that will give you an insight
about what the examine is going to be
but when you attempt the exam you will
find out that those questions are very
different from the actual exam itself
coming back to the questions the primary
goal of security awareness program is
now what is the security awareness
program and why is it created the
primary goal so is it to provide a
platform for disclosing exposure and
risk analysis to make everyone aware of
potential risk and exposure to provide
accurate risk and exposure results a way
of communicating security procedures now
the answer to this is to make everyone
aware of potential risk and exposure
doesn't mean that you are trying to make
everybody ethical hacker what you are
trying to do is in your organization you
are trying to create a security of there
in this program which allows your
employees to know what kind of policies
exist in your company what rules need to
be followed what are the procedures that
need to be followed for them to
safeguard themselves and company assets
as well and ensure that data leakage and
data loss are kept at a minimum
so you're basically trying to make
everyone aware of the risks that they
may have for example social engineering
not clicking on links not going to
unwanted sites and so on so forth
question 2 a contingency plan should
address which of the following potential
risks residual risks or identified risk
now what is a potential risk a potential
risk is something that you may foresee
in the future something that means is a
residual risk we'll come to that what is
an identified risk a risk that has been
identified is known to the organization
and the organization is aware of it so
potential is something that may come
into the future identified as something
that exists right now a residual risk on
the other hand is a risk that was
identified earlier on mitigated but
after mitigation there is still amount
of residual risk that exists so these
terminologies need to be understood
really well for it will be give you an
example of a residual risk so let's say
there is a sequel an injection a flaw
that has been identified in an
application and that's a now that's now
an identified risk now you've got two
options in front of you go to a software
development lifecycle again recode that
part of the application to mitigate the
risk or else have a secure
you control like a firewall of Web
Application Firewall watching at risk
now the ideal scenario would be that you
go through the development process again
but that is going to take time so you
put in a compensatory control that is a
web application firewall in the
meanwhile to mitigate that risk and then
have the recording done and then later
on resolve that is called together so
when we put in the firewall to mitigate
the risk temporarily is the risk
actually addressed no there is still a
possibility of a sequel injection attack
happening but we just have it mitigated
to a certain extent because there is a
firewall watching it so that means that
there is still a residual risk a risk
that is remaining even after me
integrate implementing the security
protocol or the security control that is
what the residual risk is something that
remains even after I put in a security
control which can be taken care of later
on or can be accepted and just moved
upon so coming back to the question a
contingency plan should address which of
the following either a potential risk a
residual risk an identified risk or all
of the above
and the correct answer to that is a
residual risk what is the contingency
plan a contingency plan is I still have
a security control but something may go
wrong and for that I want a secondary
control to be in place to ensure that if
the first control fails the second
control would still be able to identify
that and stop the security incident
happening so we are looking at residual
risks and then having contingency plan
to manage those residual risks question
3 when the cost of the countermeasures
outweigh the cost of the risk the best
way to handle the risk is to reject the
risk transfer the risk accept the risk
or reduce the risk now there are 4 visa
risk can be vanished right except the
risk avoid the risk transfer the risk or
mitigate the risk right rejecting the
risk is not an option but what is the
question
cost of a countermeasure outweighs the
cost of the risk so what is the cost of
a risk the cost of a risk is basically
the impact that the organization is
going to face in a monetary manner if
the risk is realized to mitigate that we
have a countermeasure in place so if in
the previous example I have identified a
sequel injection attack and the
countermeasure to that is me
implementing a security control of a
platoon firewall to mitigate that risk
however if somebody executes that risk
somebody does a sequel injection
the loss that I am facing is only $100
for incident and the maximum incidents
that can happen in a year are 10 so 10
in 200 is 1,000 dollars per annum is
what that risk is going to cost me for
me to implement a Web Application
Firewall on an annual level it is going
to cost me let's say 15,000 dollars in
licences management salaries and all of
those things which means that I am
facing a loss of $1,000 but I'm spending
fifteen thousand dollars to prevent that
loss I'd rather have the thousand other
laws then spend fifteen thousand dollars
right so in this scenario the cost of
the countermeasure
is out weighing the cost of the risk by
fourteen thousand dollars so in this
scenario which is the best way I would
do it if they reject the risk which is
never an option because you cannot
reject the risk transfer risk
what is transferring a risk transferring
it to a third party by purchasing
insurance example right so if I purchase
insurance saying if this if this gets
compromised it's the insurance company
is going to make the payments
I am safeguarded or accept the risk or
reduce the risk so in this scenario
accepting the risk is basically
accepting the risk the way it is moving
on because there is nothing that you can
do about the risk and you're willing to
accept the risk rather than spend money
on it and reduce the risk is mitigating
the risk by implementing the firewall
and spending that money and then
incurring those losses so in the best
answer out of this is accepting the risk
why can't I transfer the risk because
there is no such insurance where again
in the given example where I can get
that kind of an insurance policy
reducing the risk would entail me
spending that fifteen thousand dollars
to mitigate the thousand dollar risk
does incur in a $14,000 loss which is
against the business logic our business
needs to make money not spend money and
that's the fourth option that's left
that's accepting the risk which means we
are not going to implement the firewall
because it is out doing the cost of the
risk we are just willing to accept the
risk itself and move on
that's the first domain moving on to the
second which is asset security consists
of topics about physical requirements of
information security let's go back to
the document in hand so moving on to
domain to asset security we talked about
assets assets could be now okay let's
get into the definite
you know what an asset is asset could be
anything that has a monetary value
associated with it from the
organization's perspective it could be
data it could be virtual assets it could
be physical assets it could be anything
and everything it could be a license
right you purchase an operating system
the operating system comes with a
virtual license that installs on your
machine or or is associated with an
email address even that license as a
value does even that license will become
asset so the basic definition is
anything and everything that is all by
the organization and has a monetary
value associated with it right thus
you're going to we talk about asset
classification as well as a
classification could be data within data
itself there would be sub
classifications like confidential data
or non confidential data public data and
so on so forth
physical assets virtual assets
networking assets anything and
everything that you can come across
would be classified here determine and
maintain information and asset ownership
so your asset management program comes
into the picture and when you say asset
ownership the organization owns the
assets as they are however rules and
responsibilities that you have created
in the organization will ensure that
some assets are virtually owned by
somebody that means that they are
responsible for the well-being of that
asset so you have to identify who for
example HR now HR is a function Human
Resources but they also need IT assets
for example a payroll which will
institute a payroll software a database
write a web application server if you
will and all of these assets are now
owned by the HR department so there are
hundreds of people in HR so who exactly
owns this that's where we identify the
owner of that particular asset saying
you are responsible for the well-being
of these assets you belong to this
department so normally the head of that
department would be the owner of those
assets and would determine what kind of
access controls what kind of maintenance
management security mechanisms are
required then we talk about protection
privacy so data owners data processors
revenants collection limitations
determining ensuring appropriate asset
retention so let's say data right even
if I have data how long do we retain
data if you go into privacy acts of
organisations or of countries rather so
GDP are for a European Union GDP are
basically states that you will only
retain personal identifiable information
for as long as the organization requires
it the moment you have no reason to have
their data with you you are going to
delete that data so which means
automatically says you are going to
retain that deduct till it makes
business sense once you figure out it
doesn't it is not required you are going
to delete it in a secure manner which is
not recoverable to unwanted parties so
you have to determine those acid
retention periods we have to understand
what those attention retention periods
are so even you for your physical assets
there will be life of the set that is
associated with it
and once the life of that asset is over
even if the set is working properly you
have to discard that asset and you have
to replace it I have to do this with
security in mind then the security
controls for all of these things
understanding data States data States
could mean three different aspects data
in motion data at rest and data in use
how are you going to secure data during
all these three stages what are the
protection methods that you've only
utilize then in forest ablation
information asset handling requirements
so that's what domain 2 is all about
let's look at the questions so the first
question in domain 2 which of the
following is responsible for setting
user clearances to computer-based
information is it operators data owners
security administrators or data
custodians understand the question who
is responsible for setting your user
clearances to computer-based information
and the correct answer to that is
security administrators they are
responsible for setting the user
clearances who are going to be
responsible for allowing the user
clearances that's going to be data
owners what is generally concerned with
personal security management controls
operational controls technical controls
our human resource controls now what is
personal security personal security is
people centric security you are looking
at people and you're ensuring that their
security comes into the picture
technical controls can be used for data
assets or physical assets like
information technology but technical
controls may not be that relevant for a
human a firewall is not going to help
anyone any which ways
management controls are administrative
controls that means a policy that will
help you implement controls but for
personal security is the operational
controls that are going to be associated
with it which of the following factors
determines the frequency of information
security audits in any human
so the age-old question for you to
remain secure how often do you want to
conduct a security audit to verify your
vulnerabilities your penetration test to
verify your security controls are
working properly so would it be
dependent upon asset value the
risk-based approach management
discretion or level of realized threats
and here the answer to that question is
risk the moment a risk is identified for
example at what various stages would a
security audit be triggered for an
individual asset as well and that can be
tied down to incident management change
management and problem management so if
there is an incident a security incident
with a database server where there has
been an attack on that server I probably
want the security audit done on that
server to identify vulnerabilities flaws
and then to mitigate those risks
similarly if there is a change that has
been going on into your organization you
first want to go into a risk assessment
strategy and then you want to look at
security audit space on the rest that
you have identified right so a security
audit is not only periodic based on
compliances or regulations but it also
can be integrated really well in your
incident management problem management
and change management scenarios that's
domain number two all right let's talk
about domain 3 security architecture and
engineering now this is where you tie up
security architecture and enterprise
architecture if you look at the first
domain we have talked about risk
assessments you have talked about
confidentiality integrity and
availability and then you have moved on
to the second domain where we talked
about asset security so that's where we
talked about data or data classification
as a classification now it starts off
with the enterprise level architecture
so something like TOGAF what is
enterprise level architecture it's
basically data center architect and a
network architect trying to create data
flows deciding how communications are
going to happen between various devices
they're going to try to do network
segmentation for web application servers
database servers look at network
isolations network access control lists
and may even decide how firewalls and
where firewalls would be required once
that architecture is created we need to
secure that architecture to ensure that
whatever data communications are
happening within that framework they are
secured in a manner where
all the risks that the organization will
be exposed to or either managed
mitigated accepted transferred whichever
the way it is right so here you start
off with physical security you start up
with trusted platform modules so looking
at the outline this is where it starts
off with implement and manage
engineering processes using secure
design principles so this domain we'll
talk about using TOGAF and then using a
Zachman framework to interact with all
the data owners all the asset owners
carrying them about security of the sets
the requirements because it is what the
security architect who determines how
secure the device will be it is the
asset owner who determines the
requirement of security for example
continuing with the HR example that we
were talking about earlier if the HR
department of head is responsible for
the database for the payroll application
it is that person who would be
determining the security levels so based
on the security architecture let's say
Zachman framework we would create a
questionnaire that needs to be filled
out by the asset owner the HR department
of head and would be supplied to us the
security heads and then we would try to
create a security profile based on their
requirements so if the HR the power
department head comes back to me and
says that they require to be adhering to
a particular standard or they want X
kind of security it is us who will
validate that requirement and it is us
who will execute it and protect that
asset based on their requirements so
this is where your server security
architecture meets enterprise
architecture by using various frameworks
this domain will introduce you to not
only Zachman framework it will again
take you to a trusted platform module it
will talk about ID secti CSEC Common
Criteria and so on so forth so this is
again a very extensive module some
people struggle with it because it is a
largely theoretical module and some
people would struggle with the concept
of how what is the security architecture
and an enterprise architecture it is
very important to understand the
differences between them for example
TOGAF is an enterprise architecture
where a datacenter architect would
deploy and streamline those devices on
which a layer of
security architecture such as ISO 27001
would be implemented to enhance the
security and ensure that the
infrastructure remains protected at all
point in time this module will also deal
with managing four abilities on assets
applications web-based systems mobile
systems and embedded devices so this is
where your engineering comes into the
picture by this module we mean when we
are deploying infrastructure we need to
engineer it with security in mind we
need to architect in such a way that
security enhances the business needs
business requirements and they are
executed in a secure manner let's look
at a few questions based on domain 3
question 1 when a computer uses more
than one CPU in parallel to execute
instructions it is known as multi
processing multitasking multi threading
or parallel running now here we need to
understand what is the difference
between multitasking multi threading
multi processing in parallel running now
it would be very difficult to explain
all these processes in this video so
here we are talking about executing
instructions
that's multi processing multitasking is
performing multiple tasks at the same
time multi-threading is where processes
create their multiple threads to manage
certain functions here when we
apparently executing instructions it is
known as multi processor question two
who mediates all access relationships
between subjects and objects of the
system now what is the subject what is
an object and what are acces
relationships so access relationships
would be your permissions that you have
created now what are permissions
permissions would be something that a
person is authorized to do so if you
look at the CIA which we discuss in the
module one confidentiality integrity and
availability how do we keep data
confidential by only allowing authorized
users access to that data
what are authorized users authorized
users or people so even people who have
been identified and are allowed access
to certain resources how do we do that
by having an identity and access
management platform in place which will
be discussed later in the next mod
domain but confidentiality will include
I Triple A standards I Triple A starts
with identification authentication
authorization and accountability
identification is identifying the person
who they
our authentication is verifying that
they are actually who they claim to be
authorization is where the access
relationships come into the picture
where we once we have authenticated a
user we are creating a matrix which
allows them access to certain resources
to a certain extent
some may have read-only access some we
have modify access of may have delete
access etc so in this scenario we are
talking about access relationships
between subjects and objects of a system
and who mediates that now when you say
reference kernel information flow model
or security kernel of firewall in this
particular scenario for this particular
question based on the options that are
available we are talking about a rule
based access control system which means
that you have created rules of what is
allowed into a network and how what is
are not allowed within the network this
can be controlled by using a firewall so
this can be controlled by using a
firewall question 3 which of the
following is not a spam blocking
architecture now what is spam and how
you going to block it it can be at the
client side it can be on the email
server variable unified spam filters
could be application based in this
scenario male bar blocking service is
basically you creating a blacklist which
will lock emails from certain addresses
or from certain things so this is not a
spam blocking architecture it's
basically a blacklist or you're blocking
emails but spam blocking architecture
could either view the email server based
could be at the client side where they
using let's say Microsoft Outlook
Express and if related rules within it
or could be on an application where you
have configured rules over there
moving on to domain for now this is
where the technicalities come into the
picture communication and network
security the network security domain
covers topics focused on protecting the
network of an organization so
communications TCP channels UDP channel
is a TCP IP so you come across the OSI
layer you map those I lever the TCP IP
layer and see how a data fragment packet
is created looking at domain 4 we are
talking about the OSI layer open systems
interconnection compared to the TCP IP
or the transmission control protocol
over Internet Protocol models you're
talking about Internet Protocol itself
you are talking about converts protocols
software-defined networks wireless
networks then we are talking about
securing network components
we talked about firewalls types of
firewalls endpoint security network
access control devices and we look at
them over virtualized network swipe
multimedia looking at doctor were
talking about remote access data
communications right so all of this is
concerned within domain for now OSI and
TCP itself could take hours for people
to understand for people to comprehend
how computers work now these are
theoretical models and we need to create
an understanding of how Theory merges
with the practical world let's look at a
few questions what is the purpose of
using a VPN now the sense over here is
what is a VPN or a virtual private
network how was it created what
technologies can be utilized within it
what encryption mechanisms can be
utilized and why are we creating that
encryption mechanism in the first place
so is it to secure remote access into a
network securely connect to networks
together security Tartarian within the
network or all of the above so here with
a VPN we are basically trying to do
everything we are trying to create
encrypted tunnel between two systems or
two networks where data can be
transmitted in a secure manner where
man-in-the-middle attacks or network
based attacks would be mitigated a VPN
can secure packets from data link layer
onwards to the application layer
question 2 which of the following
characteristics are not included in the
TCP protocol now what is the TCP
protocol TCP is a connection-oriented
protocol it is a reliable protocol that
is utilized to communicate between
servers in a reliable manner so what do
you see P protocol being a
connection-oriented protocol which is
reliable in nature so which of the
following characteristics are not
included connectionless protocol that is
the UDP protocol so this is not included
in the TCP protocol question 3 which if
you remember the previous slide would be
the UDP protocol UDP protocol is a
protocol that is used for its speed
rather than reliability when it is
real-time processing that is required we
use UDP so most of our wiped out
communications would happen over UDP
protocols
ok so looking at domain number 5 domain
5 talks about identity and access
management so this ties up with your
at management your risk management
because if we go back to the
confidentiality integrity and
availability aspect of it identity and
access management is basically a loving
authorized users access to resources by
authenticating them and also holding
them accountable so this becomes the
sense of how you're going to allow
people to access the resources that you
have in your organization let's look at
what this domain covers it will talk
about physical and logical access to
assets so servers need to be protected
by putting them in a secure server room
does this tic-tac restricting access to
them and allowing access only to those
few people who require access to them
once we have secured those servers this
is where we talk about physical security
whereas we've got a secure room you're
going to monitor that room we will have
access controls we will have guards
monitoring who is getting access on
who's trying to get access to that
environment and then you're going to
create logical access as well where we
let's say I have swipe cards on the door
locks so anyone with logical swipe card
can access that particular facility
you're also looking at managing
identification and authentication of
people devices and services so here we
are going to talk about authentication
mechanisms single authentication
multi-factor authentication we are
talking about single sign-on so we will
talk about federated in identity
management modules we'll look at cash be
a cloud access service brokers we will
talk about session management from
applications and so on so forth we will
also talk about third-party identity as
a service provider where we integrate
those identities like open ID into our
organization and we validate people
based on the identity that they have
created with those organizations then we
talk about access control lists which
would be role based access controls
mandatory access controls discretionary
access controls attribute based access
controls rule-based access controls and
then there are a lot of theoretical
models that are integrated in this
module which talk about lattice based
approach which we'll talk about other
theoretical models which will help you
align how Identity and Access Management
is implemented in an organization so at
this point in time we will also be
looking at a life cycle of how identity
these are managed for example onboarding
of people deboarding of people
termination of employees employees as
they move within the organization by
hitting promotions demotions or changing
departments and assuming a new rule so
here we talk about how we can provision
an identity how we can be provision an
identity how it is pre managed we going
to create a relationship between the
creator of this identity and the
approver who's going to be a manager so
even if somebody's allowed to create an
identity they will only create it if
they have an approval from our
appropriate manager so let's look at
questions from domain number 5 the first
one which of the following is the most
important factor while selecting a
biometric system for securing critical
assets now you're the domain talks about
the types of authentication mechanisms
there are five types essentially three
basic types which talk about something
that you know which is a password
something that you have a swipe card
someone that you are a biometric
somewhere that you are location-based
and something that you do like capture
so these are the five basic
authentication types or mechanisms that
you can utilize in an organization
multi-factor authentication is having
multiple of these options in integrated
in our identity access management module
to enhance the security now coming back
to biometrics biometrics have positives
and negatives amongst them so with a
biometric there are two types that we
talked about false rates of carry false
acceptance rate and false rejection rate
what is the false acceptance rate
somebody let's say you are using a
thumbprint to authenticate people
somebody put down their thumbprint the
person is not actually authorised
however it was read incorrectly and the
DOE got on unlocked and the person had
access to that particular area which is
a false acceptance rate a false
rejection rate is an author
authenticated or an authorised person
actually trying their thumbprint but it
not getting recognized
thus they did not get access to the area
or to the device that they wanted now
the question here is which of the
following is the most important factor
while selecting a biometric system for
securing critical assets now would I
want to focus on false rejection
of false acceptance rate then we also
have equal error rate and maximum
allowable downtime maximum allowable
downtime is if the biometric measure
fails and if nobody's getting access to
any of the resources to what level or to
what extent would my business be able to
tolerate such an outage here the correct
answer is the false acceptance rate
because if an unauthorized person gets
access to my devices that's the
worst-case scenario if the biometric
system is down and nobody's getting
access that may still be acceptable
rather than having an unauthorized
person getting access to very sensitive
data false rejection rate is also
detrimental to the organization however
it is not as bad as having a false
acceptance rate introduced in the
organization for the second question
which are the two major factors to
measure biometric performance again the
question from the previous one FA are
false acceptance rate and fr are false
rejection rate or FS e + e RR ie R + fa
r FR r + TI c they don't actually relate
so the correct answer here is f AR false
acceptance rate and false rejection
rates so these are the two major factors
false rejection rate may still be a
little bit acceptable but a false
acceptance rate is not tolerable at all
next question a commercial application
for steganography that is used to
identify documents or verify their
authenticity is either a digital
checksum an md5 hash a digital signature
or a watermark
now here the keywords matter you're
talking about steganography so suddenly
people start thinking about hiding data
within data and then if you just isolate
the words identify documents or verify
their authenticity we basically directly
go to a digital signature because that's
what we utilize for a non-repudiation
however what the question refers to is
an application foster geography
steganography
is hiding some element which would be
visible only to known people we can
utilize steganography
on how far to benefit our ourselves or
our organization by using it to identify
the authenticity of a talk or document
so if I am going to print out a document
maybe a watermark on the document which
is not visible to the naked eye but when
I want to
I did the document I would search for
that particular watermark and that is
the correct answer for this particular
question so that's what domain 5 is all
about all right let's look at domain
number six which is security assessment
and testing now this domain is all about
assessments auditing strategies and
testing so from this domain what are you
going to take away is talking about
internal audits external audits third
party audits and the security control
testing strategizing about how we
implement a vulnerability management
system a program within the organization
that is reputable consistent and
measurable can be tied up with other
management programs like patch
management incident management and
anything and everything that requires a
vulnerability assessment like even
change management if something is going
to change in an organization you can
have a vulnerability assessment done
before you want to even think about
allowing it or disallowing that change
similarly with penetration testing to
validate the vulnerabilities that you've
identified logger reviews having SIEM
tool that will help you analyze or
create a pattern analysis of what's
happening within the infrastructure
what's happening within the organization
from a security perspective there you
talking about collecting security
process data account management when you
say account management Identity and
Access Management life cycle so
onboarding of an employee off-boarding
of an employee the lateral movements of
an employee in an organization when they
getting promoted or they are transferred
in from one department to another right
so all of these would come under
security assessment and testing to see
how those policies are functioning to
analyze the effectiveness of those
policies does the requirement for
conducting vulnerability assessment and
penetration tests so let's look at a few
questions on this domain and let's start
off with the first one which of the
following ways requires the involvement
of an information security analyst so
out of these four options a systems
requirements definition system design
program development or program testing
during which phase would you involve a
security analyst now for this we first
need to identify why we require a
security
analyst what is the job requirement what
is the activity that is going to be
conducted by a security analyst right so
in this scenario the correct answer is
programmed testing in the develop
program development phase we will need
an analyst we would need a program
manager and architects who can develop a
particular program who can give it some
semblance of what needs to be achieved
if the system design it would be again
an architect who's going to develop that
system in the system's requirements
definition again so in the system's
requirements definition its requirement
gathering about what is what you need to
adhere to what is going to be the
baseline that you are going to create so
from these four options you need to
identify where would you place a
security analyst right in the exam it's
the most probable answer that you're
looking for it's not the most idealistic
answer right so from these four options
security analysts would most likely be
involved in the program testing phase
rather than any other phase the second
question which of the following
techniques is generally not used for
monitoring purposes
now when you say monitoring what is
monitoring monitoring is looking into
logs activities anything and everything
that has already happened so you are
reacting to something that has already
happened and which of these following
techniques is not used for monitoring so
you're collecting logs you're analyzing
those logs what would be not be utilized
a penetration test intrusion detection
violation processing or countermeasures
testing right now when you're monitoring
you would monitor the penetration test
to analyze if the test was successful or
not intrusion detection that's the first
input that you look at for analysis
violation processing anything is
violated any processes any policies you
analyze them and you you monitor them
does you come to know that this has
happened in countermeasures testing
there's basically a test of the
effectiveness of the countermeasures
that are already implemented at that
point in time you may not be monitoring
these the software program that acts on
behalf of user in their absence to carry
out operations is known as an agent worm
applet or a browser so a program that
acts on behalf of user in
absence to carry out operations is
either an agent and appellate or a rope
or a browser a browser is nothing but a
software that allows you to surf the
Internet
a worm is a malicious application that
would be more of a nuisance value than
anything else an applet is something
that allows you interconnectivity and
age into something that will that can be
automated used for automated tasks and
can run those tasks in the absence of a
particular user so if you look at these
questions understanding what each and
every word means understanding and
highlighting the key words in the
question itself and then analyzing the
scenario that you are placed in and then
identifying the most appropriate answer
for that particular question that is how
you want to approach the CISSP exam
looking at the next domain domain number
seven and that security operations let's
look at what Security Operations has for
us now in security operations you're
looking at looking at a sock a security
operation center so your regular both of
the management incident management
problem management change management
lacing controls analyzing all that
information so probably having an siem
tool configuring this IAM tool
collecting all those data so identifying
event sources what are event sources
when I have an assignee implemented I am
NOT going to expect this I am to
automatically start collecting data all
by itself and then again I don't expect
the Siem tool to understand what kind of
data it needs to collect so for me in a
security operation center after I have
installed an S I am told I first need to
configure it to identify which devices I
want to monitor from which devices I
want to collect that information and
where do I want to store it once I have
all that information in place after that
I'm going to analyze that data to
identify if anything has been
incorrectly going on or is there any
security incident that has happened and
those would be raised at incidences and
that would be sent to the sock team for
analysis and then an incident response
right similarly intrusion detection and
prevention logs would be utilized to
identify something that may have been
missed by the ids/ips itself you're
going to place controls for
investigations like that
controls which would be policies that
you have made then you've got criminal
laws or some if something bad has
happened that can be described as a
crime based on the law of that land how
you're going to deal with it civil laws
regularly regulatory laws and industry
standards regulatory laws would be for
example GDP are in the European Union
right a civil law would be where there
is no criminal activity that has
happened but let's say there's a breach
of contract between two organizations
and the civil lawsuit has been filed
against an organization for a breach of
service level agreements regulatory
would be the gdpr Act where you have to
report or a regulatory body and if there
are any flaws you could be fined
industry standards ISO 27001 PCI DSS and
so on so forth so when you're looking at
these requirements for investigation all
of these would have prescribed how
you're going to handle that
investigation if it is a criminal
investigation an organization by itself
doesn't have the right to investigate
they have to go to a law enforcement
agency and there is a procedure to
follow in case of a civil lawsuit there
are lawyers who would deal with this
this kind of activity send out notices
to the other party then go to a court of
law to file a lawsuit over there in gdpr
there are timelines on how you want to
report a breach or how you're going to
report an incident and so on so forth so
the security operations you're creating
a security operation center in alignment
with all of these five requirements
you're going to look at logging and
monitoring activities having that SIEM
tool which will identify those devices
that you want to monitor collect
relevant information that is prescribed
based on all those five investigation
types that we just discussed then you're
looking at when you're looking at
identification of assets you go back to
your asset inventory asset register you
look at all the assets that you have and
then you make your strategy and plan how
you want to collect those logs right and
then we'll this module will deal about
how do you want to handle identity and
access management privileged account
management service level agreements and
so on so forth so this basically is that
they do the day-to-day business activity
of an organization from a security
perspective so you are there to identify
incidents as assist you
won't be executing this but you would be
creating policies revolving all of these
aspects so you have this is what you
need to consider this is what you need
to strategize upon and this is what you
want to advise the organization so what
needs to be in place to be more
effective from a security perspective
let's look at the few questions from
this domain how does the subject get
access to an object in a multi-level
security policy now first we need to
understand what a multi-level security
policy is we need to understand what the
subject is and what an object is let's
look at options first the subject
sensitivity label must dominate the
object sensitivity label the subject
sensitivity label subordinates the
object sensitivity sensitivity label the
subject sensitivity label is subordinate
over the object sensitivity label and to
repeat the sensitivity tags again and
again the subject sensitivity label is
dominated by the object sensitivity
label too much the sensitivity in a
single slide however you can see that
this just confuses the portion of what
they're trying to read and not only you
missing what key words are so people
normally focus on a keyword called
multi-level security policy and start
getting confusion that with while we do
this regard what a subject and an object
is right so a subject and an object is a
relationship that is created between
identity and access management
subjecting the user object being the
resource that needs to be accessed by
that particular user after which comes a
multi-level security policy which is
basically the access control matrix that
you have created between these multiple
objects and multiple subjects so for
example in this domain you would also
talk about theoretical models for access
management including lattice based
approached weather sensitivity labels
come into the picture you would talk
about clock Wilson model you will talk
about build up a doula model and a few
other models right all of them
theoretical in nature which can been
based on other implementations be
implemented in a real time scenario so
all that understanding comes into
picture and then you need to identify
how those sensitivity labels in lattice
based approach could allow you to create
those labels for your subjects and
objects and then the identity access
management tool
become the verification factor where it
identifies the labels for the subject
and the object and they based on those
labels they allow or disallow
connectivity or allow connections to
happen now here the correct answer is
that the subject sensitivity evil must
dominate the objects the sensitivity
label so the user should have a
sensitivity label that allows them
access to the object which has an
equivalent sensitivity label so
understanding those models becomes very
much important not only from an exam
perspective but when you are creating a
policy you basically are going to use
these terminologies and you're going to
create a policy around this moving on
second question managers of which
Department are ideal for the development
of information security policy for an
organization business operation
information technology purchase or human
resources
now managers of which department are
ideal for development of information
security policy for an organization and
when we say information security policy
we would obviously assume that is the IT
department is going to deal with it and
it's the information technology in this
are in this case but that's incorrect it
is the business operation why because
right from the first domain so we would
be taught in the training for CISSP that
security needs to enhance the business
functionality not the other way around
so we are in the business or here in the
function of conducting a business which
will offer services and those services
that are being offered the business
activity that has been conducted should
be supplemented by security so those
business activities could be conducted
in a secure manner at no point in time
is going is security going to be your
deterrent to business the only reason
for anything to become a deterrent to
business is the legality of it if a
business is illegal
it will not happen or it should not
happen however if the business activity
is legal then security should not stop
that activity from happening security
should be implemented in such a way that
it is the business activity is
strengthened there is security embedded
within it secured by design and then the
business activity goes on so even if you
are a chief information security officer
a security manager and you go and talk
with the the Board of Directors or the
steering committee as the terms you will
come across in this training you will
understand that it is it's these people
who would define how the business is
going to work what kind of business
activity over to do and then you provide
the example and I'll give you an example
here let's say I'm an online retailer
and I want to sell goods online which is
legal I'm selling illegal goods goods
now I want security to our team to come
in and they would help me to secure the
the function of being an online retailer
if you will my security team is not
going to come and tell me of not to do
it go into that business or stop some
services because they may be insecure
right the security teams requirement is
that if I want to sell goods online they
need to now create an architecture of
devices of clouds of whatever is
required to make it secure so does the
managers of business operations will
always be the ideal department for the
development of information security
policies they decide what is what the
business is going to happen and then the
security interest complements it by
adding the security to it for example
just going on with this a website is
launched with HTTP the security team
comes into the picture and says the time
motion needs security so you want to
convert it into HTTPS and at no point in
time are they going to say HTTP is
vulnerable so we are not going to do
this we rather become a whole set shop
or something like that and I'm just
giving an example and rather than me
just rambling on let's move on to the
next question question three installing
malicious software on the system to
allow future backdoor access leads to
valuation of what integrity does it
violate the data integrity system user
or network now malicious software on a
system to allow future backdoor access
so what are we doing here we are
basically installing a software or an
application on a particular system which
allows a hacker a backdoor access to the
system so this would violate the
integrity of the system itself right the
data would be compromised but the data
would be compromised because a system
would not come from
or user doesn't matter because of
backdoor is a backdoor entry where you
can get access without even logging in
as a user and a network is just a way of
communication at this point in time but
the sense being that system got infected
and through that infection you've got
access to whatever was on that
particular system
now that's domain number seven domain
number eight which is the last domain in
the CISSP exam is software development
security SDLC or SSD LC secure software
development lifecycle right
that's what is discussion in this domain
let's go back to the CISSP guide and see
what this domain would consist of so
software development security and I can
see software development life cycles
coming in so they're going to talk about
different life cycles like what a fun
model of it they're going to talk about
a giant they're going to talk about
modified waterfall this module also will
talk about dev psych ops DevOps and
anything and everything that would be
there with the software development
lifecycle now when we say software
development lifecycle the sense of a sis
is to add another s to the SAS DLC the
SDLC sense for software development life
cycle this is adds one more is the
secure software development lifecycle so
as with everything secured by design
which means security needs to be
integrated at every phase of the
lifecycle and not should that should not
be ported on for example a waterfall
model talks about how the software is
going to be developed and how it is
going to be published or released at the
end of the lifecycle
at no point in time does it talk about
security does security accurate that
coin will die at that point in time
would come into the picture and decide
what are the requirements of the
software what what are the security
vulnerabilities or the risk that they
see so threat modeling would happen and
all those things need to be introduced
right from the inception so if there are
developers or if there is a business
requirement for an application let's go
back to the previous example I'm an e
tailor so to become an ETL and not do I
pay only in a website I will need a web
application for that function it will be
given out so I need to develop that
application in a regular life cycle
model I develop that application and
then go into security where I do
be apt on that application find out that
it there are disastrous results and then
I go back and start coding again which
is not a good scenario so I have hired a
sis who will then come into the picture
during the S DNC and in the inception
itself and businessmen are talking about
how the business is going to happen at
that point in time the SIS will come in
and start with a threat modeling
exercise saying you know what let's talk
about what are the risks this
application is going to face you're
going to hand a lot of payment
information because people need to pay
for the products right so credit cards
you're going to be going to be involved
there's a database or sequel injection
attacks so these are the threads that
we're looking at and now a threat
modeling exercise would be followed by a
risk assessment then would be looked at
upon a bit by an impact analysis and
then based on that you prioritize those
risks you will then educate your
developers to use secure coding
practices at the same time security
testing would be done to see how the
application is being evolved and then by
the time that the software development
lifecycle comes to an end you would have
a secure software which had security by
design integrated since the inception
rather than having bolted on now this is
the ideal scenario that you're looking
for the expense and the pathetic that's
where the balance of layer of capital
investments and time to market and all
that comments will come into the picture
but for the training we will always be
in an ideal scenario we'll always have
enough time enough resources monetary
and human and the exam basically looks
at a very ideal scenario in which you've
got just about everything you just need
to make the correct decision at no point
in time are you going to think that if I
start doing particular strategy it is
going to cost me a lot of money so I
don't want to do that that's the
real-world scenario in the real world
you look at the costs you look at the
timelines deadlines and then you take
informed decision of how much you want
to invest in what in the ideal world for
the suspects app or the CISSP exam there
are no limitations you are looking at
the most correct way of doing those
things and thus you are you identify
those require
and that's how you answer the exam so
you're looking at the security software
environments that you require
configuration management auditing and
logging of changes security impact of
acquired software now in this scenario
we talked about developing a software
what if I purchase a third party
software and I introduce it into my
organization
now this software when integrated how is
it going to impact my current security
controls impact price current identity
access management my networking my other
applications my communications so that's
something that you want to assess as
well right so let's go for the questions
question one in which of the following
raid level the drive area continues to
operate even if any test fails now in
the actual exam they are not going to be
very technical it's a managerial exam so
they may not ask you these kind of
questions but the knowledge is still
required so you need to know that there
is something called raid the different
levels of read because you might want to
use that as a solution in a particular
thing how do you want to implement raid
and all of those that's not the
knowledge that we want but in this
scenario raid level 7 is the ideal
answer question 2 which of the following
steps can be utilized or can be used to
protect an organization against the
failure of a critical software so now
basically what does this talk about this
talks about disaster recovery or this
talks about business continually for
example there's a failure of some sort
when there is something that fails what
does it do it interrupts the business so
the moment of business interruption
happens what should kick in the business
continuity plan if the business
continuity plan fails that the disaster
recovery plan kicks in so if you look
into it as we go in we might even come
against terminologies like our TOS our
peers written time objective and
recovery point objective and at that
point in time you want to look at how do
we want to recover from a data loss and
thus you will come across solutions now
of the four options full backups
differential backups and incremental
backups and the fourth one software
escrow agreement what is the difference
between these the full backup is a
complete backup of the entire data that
you have
now it sounds easy but in an
organization data would be terabytes
petabytes and to do a complete backup my
take days weeks or a lot of time right
it's not just copying one megabyte from
a hard disk to a USB Drive and be done
with the backup so full backups may be
possible but not on a regular basis so
maybe you do a full backup every week
which means that at the end of the week
if the data loss happens then you have
lost the data for an entire week because
the backup was last week thus it's not a
very good solution and to complement
that we could use incremental backups
and differential backups right so the
training would include all of these
definitions of what these backups are
what happens and then the fourth option
software escrow agreement what is that
now in a software development or a
software life cycle if I purchase a
software from a third party my biggest
risk is not of me getting hacked of the
have the software getting hacked from a
business continuity the biggest risk is
if the software provider goes bankrupt
or has taken over by somebody else or
stop supporting the software then what
what I might do because I may have
invested millions of dollars or
reinvesting into a different product and
migrating to a different product would
be expensive very costly and may be very
time-consuming so what do I do at that
point in time so there is an option for
software escrow agreement what does that
mean
that the source code of that software is
placed in an escrow which means let's
say in a bank where the bank will hold
this of the source code in a secure
manner and the source code cannot be
accessed or be modified either by the
developing organization or the
purchasing organization so it just sits
with the bank if the developers go out
of business or they stop supporting at
that point in time the escrow can be
opened and the purchaser that that's us
in this case can still get the source
code so now we can develop the software
or we can go into the source code
analyze and save ourselves from a
disaster right so these are the four
options now here you're talking about
the saw critical software form that
field you're not talking about data that
field so the correct answer here is the
software escrow agreement right question
number three now here we come across the
development models which one of these is
a meta model that incorporates several
other software development models are we
looking at waterfall modified waterfall
spiral or critical patch now in
describing each and every model would
take a long time that's something that
I'm going to leave for the training but
here the correct answer is a waterfall
model now there's a big difference
between waterfall and modified waterfall
as well right so that's something that
we will leave for the training for now
that's the end of the slide so I thank
you for your attention for this video
I'll see you in the next video for any
comments please make a comment in the
comment section of this video and if
there's anything I'll get back to you
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here